لا تتوقع رؤية هذه المشاهد على
التلفزيون الحكومي الروسي
عندما يتعلق الأمر بزعيم فاغنر الذي
تحدى الكرملين ثم توفي في حادث
تحطم طائرة، هناك تعتيم إعلامي افتراضي
على الحزن العام
ولم يتم سماع أنصار فاغنر مثل ديميتري في موسكو من
قبل.
الموت كما يقول يؤكد فقط أن
هناك عددًا أقل وأقل منا ممن
يفكرون حقًا في بلدنا، وتاريخنا
وأهدافنا أظهرت
للجميع حقًا كيف ينبغي القيام بذلك، لقد قام
طبيب الطوارئ الأجنبي بعمل رائع، تقول ماريا
وهم أبطال بلدنا  لكن بالطبع
يرتكب الجميع أخطاء، كما تشرح،
ولكن في روسيا، يمكن أن تكون بعض الأخطاء قاتلة، وقد
انتقد الكرملين
مزاعم مقتل بريجوسيان
لقيادته هذه الانتفاضة العسكرية الفاشلة
في يونيو، ووصفها بأنها أكاذيب مطلقة،
والحقيقة هي أن الطائرة سقطت على الأرض
بعد شهرين من اليوم الذي حدث فيه ذلك.  أثارت
الشكوك حول أن
التحقيق الرسمي
سيكشف على الإطلاق عن تورط الدولة. هناك
بالفعل مخاوف بشأن مدى
السرعة والإهمال الذي تم به
سحب الأدلة من مكان الحادث،
وعندما زارت شبكة سي إن إن صباح الاثنين، كان قد تم
بالفعل تسويتها بالأرض وإزالتها
مجرد نصب تذكاري صغير لـ Mark the Spot
لكن ذكرى زعيم فاغنر قد
لا تمحى بهذه السهولة
كلنا غاضبون مما حدث
يقول هذا الضابط العسكري السابق الذي
يترشح الآن لمنصب سياسي في
فارس الروسي الذي
نعتبره جميعًا قائدنا الأساسي
في العملية العسكرية الخاصة التي
قالها لحشود من
قد لا يعجب الكرملين المشيعين، ولكن حتى في
الموت، يواصل زعيم المرتزقة الروسي
ضرب وتر
حساس، ماثيو تشانس سي إن إن موسكو